this scene from season 3 of The CW's hit
show the hundred unexpectedly set off a
firestorm of anger and shock from its
fans this year the episode called 13
premiered on March 3rd right where this
Google Trends chart for the show pits
so what happened well these two
characters Clarke and LexA were in love
and after seasons of pining for each
other finally get together have a happy
moment LexA walks out of the bedroom and
gets shot with a stray bullet meant for
Clarke the lot of fans were deeply
deeply hurt on a level that the writers
did not anticipate so a character dies
and that seems to happen all the time
these days what's the big deal
well the scene perpetuates a pretty
toxic truth called barrier gaze where
LGBTQ characters seem to never have
happy endings the thing is that it
didn't start with television to
understand what's happening here
you have to go back to lesbian pulp
novels that sprung up in the 1950s and
60s the genre was notorious for building
up a relationship between two women and
then at the very end they would be
punished in some way Mary Jane Meeker
was one of the most famous lesbian pulp
novelists and her first novel spring
fire followed that to a tee she wrote
under a few pseudonyms including van
packer
for gold medal Meeker was told by her
editor from the very beginning that the
book should not have a happy ending or
the post office might seize it as
obscene in the end one woman goes crazy
and the other renounces her lesbianism
altogether this is why when Patricia
Highsmith wrote the price of salt which
the movie carol was based on it was
immediately a big deal it seems like
they're going to be apart forever really
the twist ending that know they're gonna
be happy together so if you if you look
into the history of queer man characters
dying off on television it goes back to
even the 70s autos treadle actually has
a pretty comprehensive list of queer
female deaths on TV one of the first
steps listed comes from the show
executive suite
from 1976 where the character Julie died
her love interest just walked into
traffic after realizing her lesbianism
and Julie was chasing her Auto straddle
currently lists 150 to clear deaths
since that moment one of the main ones
people always point to is Tara on Buffy
which actually the hundred death really
eerily near your shirt Tara the same
week as LexA a character on the
magician's was introduced as a game
woman of color and then killed herself
basically two scenes later also that
week there was Denise on The Walking
Dead got an arrow in the eye when in the
comics that happened to a white guy on
the Vampire Diaries a gay which couple
decided to kill themselves together
rather than one of them just dying so
both of them died on Empire Camilla
killed her wife meanie with poison and
then was killed herself all of these
deaths on their own might not seem that
crazy but let's put this in perspective
during the 2015-2016 TV season 22
lesbian characters that appeared in
three episodes or more were killed off
that's 25% of all female deaths on TV
and 10% of all deaths on TV so why did
Lex's death out of all of these ignite
such a visceral reaction these fans
being able to talk to the creators in a
more direct way than they've ever been
able to really accelerated a lot of his
conversations the creator of the hundred
Jason Rothenberg later apologized to
fans in an open letter acknowledging
that in trying to heighten the drama he
ended up perpetuating a disturbing trope
I would never suggest that a TV show
could never kill off a gay character if
that and things forbidden from writers
but I do think it's worth being
conscious of this trope and knowing what
they're doing when they're doing it and
making sure that the death has some
resonance and really that's what we
should be doing anyway is making sure
that a character's death means something
you
you